staying overseas american basketball
star brittany griner is preparing to go
on trial in russia tomorrow griner is
accused of smuggling drugs but the state
department says she is being illegally
detained charlie dagida has more
distraught handcuffed and heading for
the fight of her life brittany griner
was last seen on monday when she was
ordered to stand trial in a moscow court
the two-time olympic gold medalist and
center for the phoenix mercury was
arrested in a moscow airport in february
just one week before russia invaded
ukraine charged with smuggling and
transportation of cannabis after
authorities found vape cartridges
allegedly containing a sheesh oil in her
luggage
her wife sherelle says she hasn't heard
her voice since but shared that griner
is struggling and terrified through
letters i won't let them break me i know
they're trying to but
i'm going to do my best and just hold on
until i can get home and she's like but
i hope that that's quick because i'm not
okay russia expert jeff hahn says the
russians are holding griner hostage case
it's very clear that
to they did not need to bring the
severity of charges against her that
they did they chose to do that
in order to grab the us attentions and
threaten her with the worst possible
outcome
russian media has speculated that
greiner could be used as a bargaining
chip in a possible prisoner's swap for
russian arms trader victor bout serving
a 25-year sentence for conspiracy to
kill americans and aiding a terrorist
organization
supporters held a vigil outside the
russian consulate in new york praying
the two countries in conflict might find
some agreement to bring griner back home
sentencing is not expected to take place
when the trial gets underway tomorrow if
convicted griner could face 10 years in
prison the prospects of an acquittal are
grim russian prosecutors have a 99
success rate gail
oh boy that's scary to hear charlie
we're all pulling for brittany griner
and hope she comes home sooner rather
than later this is very tough